dieses video zeigt wie wichtig schwere
waffen für die ukraine sind eine drohne
filmt wie ein russischer schützenpanzer
vom typ bmw zwei offenbar versucht in
einem zerstörten gebäude im ukrainischen
mikulski in der region donezk deckung zu
finden doch das panzer versteck wird
durch eine ukrainische drohne entdeckt
durch diese bilder wird deutlich wie die
ukraine in so einem fall agieren die
unbewaffneten drohnen spionieren die
standorte der russischen verbände aus
dann werden deren koordinaten
übermittelt und die standorte mit
schweren waffen wie zum beispiel
artillerie oder raketen beschossen in
diesem fall kommt es zu einer explosion
genau dort wo eben noch der panzer zu
sehen gewesen ist die bilder werden von
experten als echt eingestuft ob es sich
bei dem abgefeuerten geschosse um eine
lasergesteuerte artilleriegranate oder
eine rakete handelt ist nicht klar